hola qué tal es un gran placer estar
nuevamente aquí con ustedes hoy en la
represa cibernética paloma martínez y
leonardo gimeno y mi persona
conocidísima persona de verdad les
presentamos el castor cibernético de
este viernes 18 de mayo en vivo y en
directo por facebook live youtube y en
nuestro sitio internet
rc y net punto sea un caluroso saludo a
todas y todos los que nos están
escuchando viviendo o escucha viendo en
este momento así es es un neologismo hay
interesante y bueno y quiero enviar un
saludo antes de lanzarnos quiero enviar
un saludo muy particular a nelson
contreras rincón y su esposa que
escuchaba en este programa todos los
viernes y con quienes tuve la
oportunidad de conversar cuando estuve
la semana pasada en barranquilla
entonces pues él me llamó
y nos pusimos de acuerdo y nos
encontramos pudimos ponerle una cara a
las voces y a los comentarios
entonces y lo mismo y viceversa no del
del lado del entonces saludos
nelson y la señora acá desde montreal y
bueno paloma porque me lo dio pero yo tú
sabes como tengo la memoria le vamos a
pedir que nos lo envíe ahorita pero
bueno no soy yo
bueno ya ves la parejita con la que les
estoy presentando el programa bienvenido
muchas gracias a ustedes aquí sufriendo
porque estábamos desesperados por estar
acá con nuestros alumnos del público
y bueno yo yo sigo martillando en el
mismo clavo por aquello y que de pablito
clavó un clavito claro entonces pero me
parece que el verano sigue arrastrando
la pata y no quiere sentarse porque está
esta mañana estaba haciendo frío
salí así muy corajudo con esto y con
esto el coraje para nosotros cuando uno
se confunde
no no no
y salí así como estoy digamos esta
mañana y tenía frío y mide la
temperatura ahora que uno tiene el
acceso a la temperatura en todos los
dispositivos y efectivamente hacían 7
grados y pensé este es un invierno crudo
en mi ciudad en argentina y yo aquí
estoy y veía los niños con éxito y
salían los chicos corriendo a veces
manguita cortas son reigosa de los
físicos muertos de la risa
y yo pensé en la mañana salía en la
bicicleta y yo pensé que iba a tener
calor porque dije 'no hay un calor me
voy a calor no es así pero es decir
estaba como suficientemente vestida
pensando que iba a estar demasiado
vestida bueno pues eso me suele suceder
a mí también pero esta mañana pues me
vestí bien me puse a una brillito me
puse mi a mi impermeable y ahí pues se
pedalier también aquí estamos el único
inteligente
es muy frágil a la temperatura no es
bueno antes de darle rienda suelta a
este castor cibernético vamos a comenzar
con alguna noticia o algo así que les
haya llamado la atención como de
costumbre no esta semana tienen algo
ustedes pues sabes que me llamó la
atención y me dio mucha tristeza al
mismo tiempo él
encargado de la investigación sobre el
accidente que tuvo lugar en el oeste
canadiense con este grupo de con este
equipo de hockey sobre el hielo de
jóvenes de 17 a 20 años máximo en el que
hubo varios muertos 17 y 17 muertos y
resulta ser que la persona encargada
entonces hizo una presentación pública
ayer en la noche y decía que encontraba
cómo fue la historia del error de la
personalidad y la identidad perdón de
uno de los niños y sí que dijeron que
había muerto una persona y se habían
equivocado y era otra entonces tenía que
arreglar el cuento no exactamente porque
él resulta hacer que la familia del niño
que se pensaba vivo pero la muerte
exacta de la familia que estaba con el
niño vivo pensando que era el suyo
estuvo en el hospital cuidando a este
chico durante varios días hasta que al
final se dieron cuenta cuando despertó
que no era el hijo porque porque había
mucho había tanto había golpe ha sido
golpeado tanto durante la acción
teniendo azúcar estaba inflamada
entonces no podían identificar los
rasgos precisos del muchachito entonces
la familia que estaba ahí junto al niño
cuando él se despertó dijo yo no soy tal
soy tal entonces los dos se dieron
cuenta que estuvieron cuidando mal a la
persona equivocada y entonces me dio
mucha tristeza porque entonces se dieron
cuenta que su hijo estaba muerto
y los que pensaron que estaba muerto lo
encontraron vivo
ay no qué historia en tos ayer el
encargado de esta investigación policial
presentó todos los detalles de cómo
sucedió y fue me dio un poco de sí y no
se les puede culpar tampoco no porque
como tú dices estaba que estaban
irreconocibles los muchachos con los
golpes que se dieron en ese
estrellamiento ahí
y bueno pues claro que la noticia pues
es seguramente muy triste para los que
aprendieron los que supieron que el niño
que creía en vivo estaba muerto entonces
no fue insólito pero fue triste como
noticia esta semana también es insólito
porque es más o menos no sé tampoco es
tan triste pero o sea así si llegara a
pasar espero que no
el isis que ganas de el estado
así que sacan fotos de ronaldo y messi
arrodillados con un cuchillo en la
garganta
amenazando para el mundial de rusia el
mundial vamos a llenar el estadio de
sangre dice la foto con esta foto de los
dos ídolos y los dos mejores jugadores
del mundo en este momento
ronaldo y messi haciendo una campaña de
guerra
claro antes del comienzo del mundial de
fútbol y eso a mí me asusta porque en
realidad pone
pone terror en la gente en la gente que
verá disfrutar de un espectáculo y esta
gente no sabe lo que hace y
evidentemente está apuntando a un lugar
muy particular donde van a tener una
expo ya tienen una exposición
importantísima solamente con este tipo
de amenazas y ocean's dios quiere que no
pase nada pero habitante evidentemente
es es feo lo que bermejo efecto lo que
esta gente hace pero puntualmente cuando
te tratan de sembrar pánico con este
tipo de actitudes y de publicidades no
le hace bien a nadie
bueno como decía mi abuelo soldado
avisado no muere en guerra entonces
quiere decir que el mensaje eso para las
autoridades hay que tener un nivel de
seguridad muy por encima de lo que a lo
mejor hayan planificado porque ya ellos
están advirtiendo que seguramente van a
cometer atentados o van a tratar de
hacerlo digamos en la historia entonces
yo creo que sí que va a aumentar la
seguridad y que van a poner
todo lo posible para que para que nada
raro pase pero al mismo tiempo hay un
montón de gobiernos que están en contra
del gobierno de rusia entonces que dice
que no van a participar y que ese tipo
de tembleque os políticos también ayudan
a que la contra se haga más fuerte por
supuesto bueno
bueno yo tengo una noticia que sale de
lo triste y que va más a asia no lo
insólito pero poco tampoco es que sea
muy cómico no pero pero vamos pasito a
pasito ustedes conocen esa famosa
canción bien ahora resulta que esa
canción es tan popular mil han tocado
está de todas las formas posibles de
todas las interpretaciones en todas las
lenguas y entonces resuelta de que una
unos hermanos un par de hermanos en la
ciudad de toronto que son acordeonistas
en acordeón la canción despacito el
problema es que están tocando dentro del
metro en los trenes del metro de la
ciudad de toronto y eso está prohibido
hay lugares específicos en los que se
puede tocar pero no en cualquier lado en
cualquier lado
entran en los vagones del metro y tocan
despacito y entonces hace una la semana
pasada le dieron una multa de 235
dólares a uno de los muchachos por estar
tocando despacito obras porque los
músicos que van al metro generalmente
van a juntar una platita que es a veces
la idea entonces lo multaron con 235
dólares y su hermano que no quiere dejar
caer el acordeón
y
tenemos el vídeo hay un vídeo por
alguien en radio canadá donde tú lo ves
a el muchacho tocando el acordeón en el
metro en despacito y bueno algunos de
los usuarios del metro algunos están de
acuerdo y dicen que bueno si esos
muchachos lo que están haciendo es
volverle agradable el paseo están en el
metro no mientras que otros que están
hasta aquí despacito
muchachos y no por la canción cambie la
canción la canción se baila también el
problema no es la canción buena sigue
hemos escuchado la canción
ese es el flores bueno a mí no me ha
molestado el problema de que una parte
de la población está de acuerdo como
ellos y otra parte de la población
o al menos de los usuarios del metro de
pronto o desaprueban eso y están en
contra entonces pues espero
y dice que sí que la toque y que le den
una vuelta si le da la gana
una cosa que me hizo
esta semana que me llamó mucho la
atención y que me dejó así con lo de él
con esto llegue nada más esto estaba de
viaje no se enteró pero igual estaba ya
aquí cuando sucede que fue un fenómeno
web en el que con una aplicación que no
sé cuál fue porque yo llegué como un
poco tarde también al debate alrededor
de esto una aplicación en instagram ves
que puedes hacer ahora pueden hacer e
intentar que la gente comente o de una
opinión sobre algo entonces pusieron un
sonido en donde escuchaba una voz dice
algo y mucha gente decía que sé es que
cedes que la que la voz decía gianni y
otra gente decía que la voz que la voz
decía logró otra bamboo completamente
diferentes como sonidos los digo gianni
y loro y no tienen nada que ver pero
resulta ser que hay una parte de la
población mundial que escucha y gianni y
otra parte de la población mundial que
escucha lo lee es la misma es el mismo
sonido entonces cuál es el truco
hay una explicación científica tiene que
ver con cuestiones cerebrales como el
célebre la grave locura en el que bueno
ni siquiera porque está por ejemplo
escucho las dos
si yo primero escuché ya ni ya ni allá
ni allá ni allá ni en un momento dado me
desconcentré bien pudo ser otra cosa me
envuelvo me volví a poner los audífonos
el vídeo partió de nuevo
ahí lo tenemos que dice que es en
nuestro público
y
i
[Música]
yo estoy escuchando mi valor también
bien escucha este ya ni olor o nada
escucho dice que escucho que está dando
bola dice
loro como yo
al escucharlo
ahorita el loro pero el otro día ya no
lo hicieron dos vídeos entonces para
confundir al joven no la gente está
confundida es viral y todo el mundo le
da
se van a llenar de plata
ponemos una vez más a ver que oyeron
nuestros holder y no quiero que ustedes
allá a ver ojos pilas digo oídos
y yo escucho ya ni llaman igual entonces
vamos a ver qué dicen nuestros oyentes
entonces ustedes entonces la pregunta
este castor lo vamos a mandar con el
debate de gianni olor se lo pusimos para
que para que nos diga si es que estamos
acá divididos
con las noticias de la semana bueno es
que tengo saludos de javier gonzález
nungaray saludos paloma los nervios
pablos de retorno de colombia cordiales
73 esas gracias gracias
nelson contreras rincón hace buenos días
cordial saludo desde barranquilla
colombia nelson como en el nombre tu
señora que el señor x olvidó si el
nombre de tu mujer
richard nelson acá porque acá los
colegas no mencione el nombre de tu
esposa entonces y ajusticiando ellos
como así que cómo es posible que esa
mala memoria que ya te estás poniendo
viejito me dicen habiéndome es no está
del todo toda la juventud que yo tengo
por delante
bueno pasemos a dar lectura a los
comentarios de nuestros oyentes que
tiene por ahí primero las damas
leonardo
tratar el vih sida temprano previene la
atrofia cerebral
alberto dice hola hace tres años fui
diagnosticado con vih positivo y
presenté meningitis por la cual estuve
hospitalizado a la fecha presentó
problemas de equilibrio y visión para
poder recuperarme algún día gracias
alberto nos escribe lamentablemente
nosotros no podemos responderle si es
una pregunta aunque está sin signo de
pregunta puede ser una afirmación espero
que así puedas recuperarte y bueno los
tratamientos vienen cada día mejor así
que supongo que probablemente haya a la
esperanza una solución en el reportaje
que estuvo leyendo justamente sobre ese
tema había información específica aquí
tengo un comentario pablo sobre el rep
él es un gran reportaje es un formato
largo que preparo leonard a leonora
chapman sobre los latinoamericanos en
que ve quién es
antes que continúe digámosle a nuestros
escucha veedores que ese es un nuevo
digamos una nueva modalidad periodística
que estamos ahora implementando aquí en
radio canadá internacional que ya existe
que tengo una duda grande porque nos
contesta nelson con tres rincones nos
pone ya ni no sé si es el nombre de la
señora lo que escucho
pero entonces decía que es una nueva
modalidad de reportajes en las que
estamos
internándonos por así decirlo aquí en
radio canadá internacional y que ese fue
el primero que se presentó por el
servicio latinoamericano van a venir
otros de vídeo les muestra y en pantalla
donde está en el sitio para que lo
puedan encontrar si tienen ganas de ir a
ver a verlo por ejemplo aquí tienen en
la parte derecha arriba a ver aprieta y
uno hace clic y aparece la página donde
está en este caso hay uno solo porque es
el primero van a venir próximamente
entre dos semanas viene uno de pablo y
rufo también
si uno hace clic y entra directamente en
este informe muy preciso y mesh ex
activo realizado por leonora chapman con
donaron a un sociólogo de la universidad
de quebec y montreal que fue el que hizo
este estudio
el tipo de población latinoamericana que
existe en quebec entonces marc perdón a
la interrupción entonces es mayor y
ramírez comenta porque comparar de
manera absoluta el salario de los
trabajadores de quebec como el de los
trabajadores de ontario de manera
general sin tener en cuenta su origen
porque no hablar del poder de compra y
de lo que cuesta por ejemplo el alquiler
de un inmueble o la matrícula
universitaria en ontario con respecto a
lo que cuesta en quebec entonces ella
hace un comentario sobre este reportajes
de leonora chapman latinoamericanos en
que ve quiénes son y creo que el mismo
tema creo que está bien este análisis
desde el punto de vista estadístico sin
embargo hay falencias en cuanto a las
actividades de los días
en la provincia de québec hay grandes
profesiones y artistas que han sido
ignorados en este reportaje por en
realidad
hay por supuesto de todo hay gente que
tiene un puesto de trabajo altísimos hay
gente que dirige empresas esto es sobre
un estudio la gente que participó está
bien probablemente esa gente no haya
participado estos datos son salidos de
que es más cuando se empezó a hacer
nosotros dimos promoción también para
que la gente de la comunidad latina
fuera y respondiera a todos los
cuestionarios para engrosar las filas de
la muestra por supuesto así que creo que
tiene que ver con eso también y creo que
lo que entendí es que el estudio como
tal no ha terminado aún es decir
hicieron una primera conclusión que fue
con los datos que habían adquirido hasta
ese momento pero si gente quiere
participar si más gente quiere
participar en este proyecto la
información está en el sitio internet
nuestro pero claro habría que entrar en
comunicación con los que realizaron el
estudio a partir de la universidad de
quebec aquí en montreal y recordemos lo
que los comentarios son valiosos para
que justamente víctor harmonie qué es el
sociólogo que dirigió este
esta encuesta pues va a recibir con
mucho placer los comentarios que le
hagan con respecto a los
latinoamericanos en quebec y supongo que
luego agregar a eventual y eventualmente
tenemos el nombre de la esposa de nelson
creció en el apuro nelson y le escuchaba
ya ni en vez de lograr así que está del
lado de nosotros
y
su señora se llama maría victoria maría
bueno perdón a maria victoria sí sí se
me había olvidado tu nombre de forma muy
temporal
en realidad creo que ya ni son las
testosteronas y lo son las no fíjate que
no las progesterona si no digo porque
ahí tenemos no pierda poder escucharlo
es dudosa la situación lo que habría
mucha gente de cualquier género que
estaba escuchando loro universo y
durante se escuchaban y además no lo
olvides cuando estoy tu parte masculina
había estado en ese momento vamos a
escuchar mejor salgo y escuchando lo
vamos a poner
comenten o me pongo el sonido ahí vamos
maestro música maestro
hay un problema
entre tres personas que les ayuda porque
aquí éramos ya tres que escuchamos y
bueno seguimos acá bueno yo le quisiera
informar a víctor alfonso barrera
ramírez emmanuel alejandro gonzález
oscar blandino dora frank rudy mais el
mono rengifo josé luís rodríguez
catherine juliette barajas jorge castro
duque betsy morillo johan gómez y
braulio ellos nos piden ayuda
como para poder emigrar o para poder
trabajar o para pedir refugio en canadá
de alguna forma y bueno nosotros no los
podemos aconsejar en ninguno de esos
procedimientos porque nosotros lo que
hacemos es que somos periodistas y
estamos acá reportando información pero
si ellos quieren tener más información
con respecto a ese trámite que hay que
hacer para poder sea venir a trabajar
schuap emigrar o osea refugiarse en la
embajada embarcada canadá en cada uno de
los lugares es más el sitio tiene
información en español también así que
para aquellos que no tengan inglés o
francés o no se sientan que no son
capaces de hacer una lectura profunda y
exhaustiva de esta información en alguna
de las lenguas oficiales pueden hacerlo
en español y la mejor manera es hacer
eso y después contactarse con las
embajadas
en cada uno de los consulados en cada
uno de sus lugares es lo más apropiado
hay gente que también hace de puente y
hace un buen trabajo y otros que no así
que que no hacen un buen trabajo digo
así que lo más porque es la autoridad
oficial con respecto a la inmigración en
canadá entonces es la mejor manera de
tratar es bueno excelente y continuamos
con con los mensajes de nuestros oyentes
hay más comentarios leonardo ahí en el
facebook
víctor es excelente bueno paloma noten
[Risas]
mosley la iglesia oficiará misas en
español en el noroeste de montreal
comenta rosas césped es excelente que se
ofician misas en español
así nos unimos más hay varias iglesias
alguien la aquí en la ciudad de montreal
y de hecho en canadá completito
de donde se hacen las misas en español y
el fin de semana pasado por ejemplo
todos los domingos casi todos los días
fuimos a una misa porque traían a la
virgen de lourdes que es la virgen la
patrona de la argentina y ésta no me
acuerdo en este momento en qué lugar ya
voy a buscar la información y función a
misa y esa iglesia de lo encontré con un
montón de gente que van seguido ahí
porque es misa en español constantemente
bueno aquí cerquita está la iglesia de
nuestra señora de guadalupe y ahí en en
nuestra señora de guadalupe siempre hay
misas en español entonces me imagino que
lo que están diciendo es que una nueva
iglesia
todas las demás que ya existen desde
hace mucho tiempo exactamente bueno muy
bien mira yo acá yo tengo seguimos
recibiendo cartas te acuerdas de aquella
publicidad cartas cuando nos la enviaba
la contestación a la correspondencia de
hecho esta carta que tenemos aquí nos la
envía justina maria saldívar saldívar
de rafael freyre holguín cuba y la envía
a correo del oyente de radio nacional
así que este programa ya no existe desde
hace muchísimos años religiosos supongo
que es rutina maría zaldívar saldívar
pues no se ha enterado del cambio que ha
habido en radio canadá internacional sí
y bueno pero si alguien la conoce hay en
cuba y que nos está escuchando en este
momento y que vive en holguín y conoce a
justina puede decirles que recibimos y
acusamos extracción se escucha y
teníamos en la época de la onda corta
pues teníamos muchísima gente mira otra
carta que nos viene de holguín que nos
envía tania espinoza pérez desde melilla
rafael freyre también holguín cuba
bueno pues están ya recibimos tu carta
muchísimas gracias por recordarte de
nosotros ahora estamos en una nueva
plataforma ya no estamos más en la onda
corta ahora estamos en las
nuevas tecnologías acá en facebook live
y en nuestro sitio internet si alguien
allá en cuba tiene acceso a las tiene
acceso a internet pues puede escuchar
nuestro programa leonas y yo quería
el comentario éste sobre la iglesia en
español que era que de qué iglesia
hablaba decía inglés el título de la
noticia era iglesia oficiará misas en
español en el noroeste de montreal lo
que porque en este caso era que yo
hablaba es la misión latinoamericana de
guadalupe es en 1969 de ontario este
esquina borde centro es donde tú vives
allá no yo estoy en el oeste noroeste
porque estás en el norte y al oeste
también
una brújula no pero lo que lo que tú
dijiste es que fuiste esa iglesia donde
llevaron a la señora de lourdes
estamos confundidos
en la virgen de luján transaron la
patrona de regina que es una muy
particular porque es una virgen hecha en
arcilla así que una virgen negra que
lindo es hecha en arcilla y ha tomado
color entonces la virgen se la conoce
como la virgen negra también bueno y
para variar un poco para no volvernos
digamos rutinarios entonces vamos a
resaltar los temas que de los que
queremos hablar esta semana y tú paloma
no sabes salta y reza para introducir mi
tema porque mi tema es musical entonces
no va a presentar a ramón chicharrón que
me parece fantástico
y apellido porque chicharrón se come
mucho en colombia
por eso los electores o selecciono eso
le puso como apellido a ramón chicharrón
por un hombre es alexander betancourt es
un colombiano viviendo aquí en montreal
hace un más o menos 10 años y está
presentando un nuevo álbum que se llama
merecumbé y estuvo aquí en nuestros
estudios hablándonos de su nuevo
proyecto musical y ramón chicharrón
tiene una en este caso en este nuevo
disco está presentando nos música que
fue a descubrir de colombia de su
colombia natal pero aquí en montreal es
gracioso porque aquí la conoció y
entonces comenzó a interesarse en este
otro tipo de música él armó era muy
cumbianchero le gustaba mucho la música
la cumbia perdón porque viene de
barranquilla creo de medellín
me equivoco
[Risas]
y tú si eres argentino
porque barranquilla está en el caribe y
medellín está en la montaña en el
interior de lunada que de todas maneras
y le encantaba la cumbia y sus otros
álbumes eran muy cumbiancheros en este
caso nos presenta otros estilos
musicales que él ha ido descubriendo
mezclas él me habló de cumbiambas pero
también de medicom ve y es muy
interesante ver que es muy cubano muy
con raíces africanas muy muy claras
entonces nos hace descubrir esa música a
través de sus ojos de alguien que vive
en canadá también entonces escucha
música un poco moderna electrónica hay
una mezcla muy interesante con ramón
chicharrón entonces vino al estudio nos
estuvo hablando de eso a bueno
fantástico y ya aprovecho aprovecho para
decir que en la edición web que vamos a
poner en nuestro sitio internet esta
tarde mismo vamos a escuchar la música
de ramón chicharrón y ésta va a ser la
música con la que vamos
perdón a la interrupción quería decir
eso que en realidad el reportaje que
presento es una entrevista en estudio
con él a la que le agregué musiquita
para los que están aquí en monte el
escuchándonos ramón presenta su álbum la
próxima semana el 24 de mayo a quien
monte el excelente y bueno tú me tienes
intrigado desde hace rato de árbol y
menos porque tú vas a hablar de dormí o
que no sé qué es y que creo que la
procedencia es todavía más intrigante
porque porque es el instituto
tecnológico de massachusetts mit y el
que habla de dormir
danos más detalles bueno en realidad
esto es algo encontré
salió hace un par de semanas yo lo
encontré esta semana y me llamó
muchísimo la atención tiene que ver con
un nuevo es como un sistema completo
con un guante que ustedes pueden ver en
pantalla en este momento y después bueno
ese guante tiene como distintas
aplicaciones puntualmente una de ellas
es mantener a la persona en un estado de
sueño lúcido o y nagoya así se llama es
el primer estado que en realidad tampoco
está muy investigado pero es el primer
estado donde cuando uno se está
durmiendo que parece que está dormido
que entiende cosas que vienen desde
afuera y que mezcla la parte onírica con
la realidad como de la siesta yo mis
fiestas las hago siempre así que esa
mente el momento es ese el momento donde
uno se acuerda de los sueños bueno en
realidad esta gente descubrió con este
proyecto que uno puede
y realzar la inteligencia la memoria y
un montón de cosas de la mente gracias a
una interacción directa de estímulos
puntuales en ese instante eso es lo que
hace dormir puntualmente es no dejar que
la persona que haya un sueño profundo y
mantenerla en sueño semi profundo está
esta especie de limbo entre la realidad
y el sueño y por ejemplo lo que hicieron
como test es enviar el aparato en la
mano no permite que no se duerman del
todo y envían palabras y las palabras
que uno le dicen cuando está en ese
estado son las que generan el sueño el
ensueño el sueño el sueño el sueño los
sueños entonces está mezclando una parte
que nosotros en realidad no tenemos con
control que no podemos soñar con algo
que queremos uno se acuesta pensando en
soñar con algo pero no sueña con eso
sueña lo que quiere el inconsciente de
amor en este caso está manipulando el
inconsciente para poder soñar y de esa
manera aumentar la
capacidad mental de relación mental y de
pensamiento y agilidad con este nuevo
sistema era de más fase de desarrollo
pero cuánto tiempo duró el tratamiento
de ella no no no se especifica estar en
fase de testeos y lo interesante el tema
es que han podido lograr que la persona
se mantenga en esta fase está bien que
hasta ese momento no se podía y en el
artículo original del instituto de
tecnología de massachusetts hablan de
que tesla y otros investigadores de
antaño trataban de hacer eso no sé si
fue tesla el que se dormía con una con
una bola de nivel de acero en la mano y
cuando caía hacía ruido y se mantenía en
ese estado para despertar para no
dormirse profundamente volvía a hacerlo
no no porque uno descansa igual o sea
cuando uno duerme
el cerebro no para esta bien sigue
constantemente trabajando no es que el
cerebro se apaga cuando no duerme uno
duerme se apaga cuando no se mueve bien
o sea el cerebro sigue trabajando cuando
uno está durmiendo lo que hace el
cerebro es regenera montón de células y
se reactiva y descansa de otras maneras
bueno en este caso lo que hace lo que se
busca es sacar provecho a este estado de
semiconsciencia de y me cuesta acordarme
de nagoya que es como hipnotizado por lo
tanto no se ocurre con magia
hipnosis con magia pero para lograr este
mezclar los micro sueños que le daban de
esa manera con la realidad y lograr
afianzar a la persona en sus
conocimientos y en su experiencia
personal bueno muy interesante eso no ya
no va a poder uno dormir tranquilo
italia esto es justamente para
intranquilizar los dormidos
el proyecto lo vamos a ver vamos a soñar
y después veremos yo antes quisiera
presentar bueno rufo valencia debía
estar con nosotros hoy pero
desafortunadamente pues por razones
mayores no puede estar y él pues tiene
un reportaje que hizo sobre un
inmigrante que fue injustamente acusado
de terrorismo aquí en canadá y este
inmigrante está ahora él se llama
ajustician abdelrazik está ahora
demandando al gobierno de canadá por esa
injusticia pero vamos a dejar que ruffo
nos presente el mismo
ese es el reportaje que está estimados
amigos el tema que yo recomiendo para
este fin de semana es un reportaje sobre
a búsquedas del racing vélez un
inmigrante que fue injustamente acusado
de terrorismo y él ha demandado al
gobierno canadiense un pago por daños e
indemnización de 27 millones de dólares
la diferencia en él
o marcada por ejemplo quien fue un
canadiense que estuvo prisionero por 10
años en la prisión militar
estadounidense en guantánamo fue que
khadr fue acusado de haber dado muerte a
un militar estadounidense hubo un juicio
impugnado por el mundo jurídico
internacional pero el caso de agustina
de racing es más grave según su abogado
paul champ porque él explica que a
burriana de rasic fue arrestado en sudán
en 2003 cuando llevaba a cabo una visita
a su familia y fue impedido de regresar
al país por orden expresa del ministro
de entonces en estas relaciones
exteriores lawrence cannon que se negó
contra el consejo de los propios
miembros del gobierno de darle un
pasaporte para que él pueda regresar a
busque anas de racing fue detenido en
sudán según la inteligencia canadiense
él sería un miembro de al-qaeda cosa que
no fue comprobada y lo concreto es que
nunca
una sola acusación contra el entonces su
demanda es que el gobierno canadiense le
privó de sus derechos básicos como
ciudadano canadiense de regresar al país
entonces es en ese marco que busca nada
de racing estaba negociando con el
gobierno una indemnización pero
justamente debido a que tras el pago de
esa indemnización a omar khadr la
reacción del público canadiense fue de
rechazo a esa decisión del gobierno
entonces el abogado paul zak explica que
se debe a cálculos políticos por los
cuales el gobierno canadiense ha
decidido retirarse de la negociación y
tomar el camino de los tribunales el
reportaje se llama que nada enfrenta a
la demanda de un inmigrante injustamente
acusado de terrorismo y esto está
nuestro sitio web eres en el punto sea
bueno listo entonces bueno decidimos les
suerte porque si gana la demanda son 27
millones no que nunca caen mal
y que lo acusen que no lo acusen que lo
de se acuse limpiar la imagen y después
la otra número no ya porque ha debido a
sufrir mucho este hombre fue acusado
injustamente de terroristas y ya sabemos
cómo se les trata a los que se acusa de
terroristas aquí en norteamérica y en
cualquier lugar del mundo o sea que te
acusan de terroristas pues es lo peor
digamos que te podría pasar para de
cosas peores también pero estar en un
campo de refugiados y tiene que vivir la
guerra todos los días yo creo que eso
también va en realidad no no no tenemos
trabajo no se puede las peras con las
manzanas
y bueno yo por mi parte les quiero
hablar de un reportaje que hice con
respecto a una declaración que hizo
el françois lego que es el líder de un
partido que se llama coalición a venir
quebec que podríamos traducir como algo
así como coalición para el futuro de
quebec o algo así digamos parecido y
bueno pues este señor françois alegó que
hasta el momento está liderando en la
red los sondeos para las próximas
elecciones de la provincia de québec
están ahora en agenda octubre son pronto
entonces en esta semana el miércoles de
esta semana presentó este famoso
documento de orientación sobre la
inmigración en el que bueno entre otras
cosas él dice que si es elegido primer
ministro va a reducir el número de
inmigrantes que la provincia recibe
anualmente que son 50 mil él lo bajaría
a 40.000 ese es una de las de las
propuestas que él hace
entre otras cosas lo que este documento
sobre la inmigración dice y ese es un
documento reciente de ahora del mes de
mayo él dice que los inmigrantes
llamados económicos se deben someter a
tres exigencias en particular la primera
es que un que tenga un dominio
suficiente del francés en un momento
dado en su en el transcurso de su
proceso de integración a la sociedad
quebequense que el inmigrante tenga un
dominio de fácil a su juicio al parecer
no no era económico no una cosa en
realidad dependiendo de su nivel
económico y tenía que hablar francés
antes de llegar no nosotros yo no tuve
yo no como económico sino como
inmigrante y calificado es una cosa
económicos y aquel que trae dinero para
poner un negocio allá o inversa como
inversor inversionista bueno el tiempo
pasa rápido entonces la segunda es que
el que tenga conocimiento de los valores
quebequenses y que demuestre que sí
o sea quedarse en la provincia tiene que
estar en búsqueda de un trabajo
en una búsqueda activa de trabajo que
son cosas que a mi juicio pues las hacen
todos los inmigrantes pero al parecer al
juicio de este señor françois ligo no
hacen suficientemente esfuerzo los
inmigrantes y bueno desafortunadamente
se nos acabó el tiempo que teníamos para
este castor cibernético en los controles
técnicos hoy estuvo sentarse en su hogar
gracias chantal por allá tenemos a
pierde útil pierde el útil que también
le decimos acá nosotros es esta paloma
martínez y martínez leona
ya ni hablo ya ni comes barrios atrás
gracias a todos ustedes por su amable
sintonía y nos veremos la semana próxima
como les decíamos el programa en en
nuestro sitio internet va a tener la
música de ramón chicharrón para que
conozcan la música de este colombiano
que está haciendo aquí en montreal
y bueno pues se nos acabó el tiempo no
nos podemos despedir sin decirle adiós
un saludo a toda la gente que llama a
todos los espías que nos están
escuchando el vino se divierten no
mientras que están con nosotros eso sí
fue todo adiós y hasta la próxima chau
hasta la semana próxima